all right let's play
I oh really
okay no I'm going to tell the truth
today brother this is hot ones versus in
front of these contestants is a stack of
deeply personal questions they can
either tell the truth I get canceled
today or suffer the Wrath of the last
dad whoever eats the most Wings loses
are you ready I'm
ready
this was rigged this you rigged this I
didn't how you fig I riged it okay what
I got to do
now are you ready I'm ready okay Emilio
uh you are best known for playing the
boss of a biker gang on Mayans and Sons
of Anarchy but you actually bought your
first motorcycle at 14 and got into
nearly a dozen dang a dozen accidents
you only told me about that one I was a
wild I know about a dozen that's a chea
out man all right what is the most
Reckless stunt you have ever pulled on a
bike I I have to answer truthfully there
some stuff that I mean I won't do to me
incriminating myself but this won't
incriminate me but it's a good story you
know it happened I was 14 can't cat me
no more okay go ahead I'll tell you I'll
tell you the
story one time when I when I first got
that bike I was getting chased by the
cops and um as I was coming in the
neighborhood I was going to make a left
turn without putting without putting the
brakes on right so when I I came in
there was a car in that lane already so
I went hit on with a par car I was young
I was skinny and I flew over the car
landed on the back of the trunk but I
was still getting chased by the cops so
the drilling got me I got up got on the
bike the forks were pushed in and I
drove home just like that I got away and
I'm good a long time ago so I'm good
statue limitations were good I I would
have ate the wing personally but yeah
okay yeah I know a long time ago long
time ago yeah 14 years old Brother come
on Gabriel your brand of Comedy appeals
to people of all ages and backgrounds
but what's one joke you've kept in your
drafts because you're sure you'd get
cancelled if you said it on
stage oh that that sounds like a bite to
me
brother
Booyah God ah [__] yeah all right okay
yeah I'm not going to say that joke and
get my ass canceled not today A lot of
people are going to see this and yeah
it's it's it's a good one all right
let's
play [__] I said really
yeah really okay I'm going to tell the
truth today brother bro it'sit like that
I'm going to tell the truth bro bro
oh let me tell you guys something right
now I've done the Regular Show hot ones
right there's a buildup they start off
with like a really really mild hot sauce
and then you eat yep excuse me you eat
it and you're you're like ah this is
weak I got this and then sorry it starts
to progressively get hotter and hotter
and hotter I swear that was happen over
here do we got a we do we got a medic
this is death death out the gate thanks
for letting me know G that you were
first this might be the first episode
and the last
episode
oh bro all right this is uh
[Music]
sorry I'm not trying to blow that your
way bro right all right go this is a
friendship test wow really now now it's
a test okay I have a very
specific Starbucks
order what is it I'm going to write it
down okay so you don't say that I'm
cheating or something okay and in case
anybody thinks that oh I turned it into
something that's not real I have people
here that can verify that this is my
this is my order okay do I have to get
it perfect I just give you like what it
is you dig can I see him when he it it
said a I'm going to reread it I have a
very specific Starbucks order it doesn't
just say hey does he like coffee okay
okay okay okay you know and you're over
here asking for Clues man hey I got it
I'm going to give you a just a straight
up answer okay I've seen it one time on
on your Instagram chai
Frappuccino chai fra who who do you hang
out with I don't chai Frappuccino uh no
you're going to eat a wing right now but
um watch this what is my Starbucks order
Trenta iced coffee with extra heavy
cream 12
spender but how am I supposed to know
all that that's a lie bro that's a lie
well cuz I'm very public about what I
drink I'm always posting pictures you
know and I'm always tagging Starbucks
cuz I want free [__]
bite bite
okay [__] eat it bro eat
it [__] oh now it does build up I
thought it's was good right now oh you
thought you were good you're like nah
that's okay it's got that back end kick
yeah
see okay yeah yes it's like eating Vicks
huh I I don't I don't do uh milk man so
like thank you for being a rocky roll
[__] okay it's my turn okay good it is
your turn okay what movie always gets me
to cry
you how how the [__] would I know what
movie makes you
cry are you public about it have you
ever put out there I cry about a lot of
movies we got to figure out which one
makes you cry the most we both cry dude
I'm about to cry right now is this movie
from the 80s '90s I think the 70s or '
80s can you at least narrow it down to
the decade no no okay I would say 7s cuz
the book is beautiful and so is the
movie oh it's a book should I give him a
hint cuz I don't want him you know to
eat another Wing cuz I you're my friend
and I don't want you to get hurt you
know you know what bro I would
appreciate one more hint it's a it's a
it's about a it's a well don't tell me
the whole don't don't actually give away
the pl it takes place in the country the
hills you know mountains yes I'm going
to I'm going to say uh oh Yeller oh [__]
bro he cheated how did I cheat oh my God
you got it bro [__] he G that
beautiful
wow all right okay this is a wild
card does that mean you eat two two
Wings if you lose or what what was that
all about that means the budget for this
show is limited and uh I can confirm now
that we're not getting paid challenge
your opponent to a staring contest
whoever blinks first must eat a
Deathwing they want the two Mexicans to
Mad Dog each other I've died many times
with my eyes open bro so I can do this
[__] all
right
[Music]
okay he binked he
binked can we try can we try it again of
course of
course yeah I don't I don't I this
hurts you're good
dude I started
to [__] you see he's going to make me
laugh he always makes me laugh it's
[__] not fair jeez okay all right
fine I blinked all right
dude
[Music]
[__]
bro and I'm not you know I know people
are I'm sweating watching you
brother I know people are watching right
now and they're like n they're they're
acting they're
fake
no fun oh bro thank you for sharing your
Rocky room it's good it's good I Gabriel
you've appeared as a guest on some of
the internet's biggest comedy podcasts
rank these comedians turned podcast SS
from funniest to least funniest
o i can name the name right okay it
would be Bobby Lee Andrew Santino Bert
kryer and Joe
Rogan is that worth a bite brother oh
I'm going to I'm GNA I'm GNA I I'll tell
you who's funny and who's yeah I I don't
care I don't care they know they know
okay as far as uh podcast just look The
Comedians in general just them as
comments ah [__] cuz the podcast that's
easy but if I got to rate them as Comics
that's different
um
wow oh
God Bobby Lee Andrew Santino brick ker
Joe
Rogan Gabriel I also don't want you to
hurt your if you want to the podcast
that's a good man that's a good man
right there you know what and and shout
out to all those comedians uh you know
to Bert to Andrew to Joe and and to
Bobby Lee uh they've all had me on their
shows and it's it's all been very
beneficial and I always want to keep it
cool so I am eating this for all four of
you
[__]
a that is a good man right there oh God
whoever wrote these questions man you're
a dick all
right okay it's a tradition oh it's a
tradition it's episode one but it's a
[__] tradition sorry for the cussing
but you know what I'm I'm on fire right
now so I don't really care it's a
tradition around here to put a little
extra on the last Wing ah yeah guess it
is you and your opponent can add an
extra dab to your final Wing now so just
a dab would do
you oh that's not that's not D no that's
a that that's a that that's not D I'm
going to take that I'm going to take his
that's kind of Sportsman I am you know
bro you want to die oh really yeah okay
you know [__] that I'm going to try
another one no look let me show you show
Da yeah a dab is just like that's that's
a lot bro it comes out quick that's a
lot that's a lot I almost feel like you
know what like I'm I'm going to do this
one right here where I don't want to
touch your wing but I don't think you're
going to bite the corner so just
little question now hold on
okay oh God last C good fans might be
surprised to learn that you performed as
a stand-up comedian early on in your
career a lot of people don't know that
but yeah that's how we met as a fellow
comic what are some ways I could improve
my standup
set you yeah yeah so what what advice
would you give me to make me a better
comedian brother
you how could I how could I give you any
advice on that well I think that's the
whole point of the question is is is so
give me advice or e p Chila
dude [__] okay I'm think of something
now I I can't man cuz every time I go
see you flu you you you you bring the
house down and you make me wife me and
my boy laugh you know you got me you
guys got me on that one good man [__]
here we go
hando oh here you go bro it's
coming it's coming oh that was worse
bro you know
what [__] let's go at it bro oh oh shoot
okay cu the hiccups all right bro I
know just just get
yeah well I've never heard that sound
come out of you
bro it's like you just watch o yella
bro I love you
boy that was [__] up
right Gabriel you made history when you
became the first comic to perform at the
Dodger Stadium how big was a fine you
had to pay for going overtime that night
oh I got no problem with this one man I
had no problem with this one uh the fine
was over $200,000 for going over my time
at Dodger Stadium it's one thing to go
over on your time at a comedy club but
it's very expensive to rent a stadium
unions and fees and stuff so because I
went over like it it rolled into the
next day so the fine was over
$200,000 wow I was there that night you
did set and then the cameras are rolling
he goes are we done they say we're done
he goes okay now we party and he open
the bottle and I pulled out I pulled out
a bottle of p in front the red cup and I
it was a beautiful night best night of
my life yes it was all right well the
rulers whoever ate more Wings lost and I
lost Emilio you are the winner of the
versus Premiere so that's for you bro
thank you Gabe thank thank you for
having me um I want to thank everybody
who came out today and see me uh eat
These Wings over here I'm glad I won I'm
real competitive you know I like I'm
going put this in the shelf for my other
trophies I don't have at home we're
doing the fifth season right now the
family business I got like a three
movies coming out in a couple of TV
shows if you follow me on Instagram
you'll see I'll start plugging them
pretty soon Gabe I really thought that
you were going to win but maybe on the
season finale you can we can come back
together no we're we're coming back
we're coming we're coming back I'm not
ever doing this I hold this one dearly
to my heart thank you very
much Benny come here come here come here
good boy binnie ah hi don't kiss me
because I'm I'm on fire right now I'm on
fire float like a butterfly stand like a
camera guy what is up spice Lords camera
guy Bill here if you like that episode
of versus be sure to hail that subscribe
button down below to stay up to date for
all the latest first we Feast
episodes